- [Narrator] Hey there friends,
all of my life,
I've struggled with asthma.
And normally it doesn't
bother me too much,
but when it's really cold outside,
or if I've worked out really hard,
my asthma symptoms get worse.
When this happens,
or in other words, when
I get an asthma attack,
the airways in my lungs
become inflamed and swollen.
And then also start to
narrow and fill with mucus,
making it harder and harder
for me to breathe normally.
However, it's not just the cold
and CrossFit that trigger my asthma,
but it's also air pollution.
If I'm running around outside,
or even just walking in areas
where there's a lot of traffic
and cars driving around,
my asthma will flare up immediately.
But why?
Well today, we're going to learn
about the connections between
pollution and human health.
This figure illustrates the
three main sources of pollution
in our surrounding environment,
namely air, water, and soil pollution.
Exposure to these pollutants can in turn
lead to a variety of
health issues and diseases.
And today we're going to focus
on air pollution in particular.
Toxic gases, particulate matter,
and chemicals released into the air
can cause a variety of health issues,
including respiratory and
cardiovascular illnesses,
as well as headaches, fatigue,
cancer, nausea, and skin irritation.
Yet doctors and researchers
are still learning about the connections
between pollutants in our environment
and human health issues,
mainly because we humans
collectively experienced
different levels of exposure
to a variety of pollutants and toxins.
So in short,
it can be really hard to
pin down the exact cause
of certain diseases
because pollutants and
toxins can enter our bodies
from the air, water and soil,
as shown by this figure,
which indicates the many
anthropogenic sources,
that is to say sources
caused by human activities,
of air, land, and water pollution.
If we take a closer look of
air pollutants in particular,
we see a cluster of industrial facilities
releasing chlorofluorocarbons, CFCs,
which are anthropogenic compounds
that contribute to ozone
depletion in the stratosphere.
We also see nitrous
oxides and sulfur dioxide,
which can contribute to air
pollution as well as acid rain,
and carbon dioxide, which
is a common greenhouse gas.
So how do these common air
pollutants affect human health?
One of them or well-studied connections
between air pollution and human health
is the link between
asbestos and mesothelioma.
Many studies have shown
that the repeated act
of inhaling or accidentally
swallowing asbestos
is the most common cause of mesothelioma,
which is a type of cancer
that develops the lining of the lungs
and sometimes in the
abdomen and heart as well.
It might be a little difficult
to see in this chest x-ray,
but this area is circled in orange
shows affected lung tissue
where mesothelioma has started to spread.
Normally the lung tissue
should appear fairly
transparent in x-rays,
but it becomes opaque when
mesothelioma is present.
Asbestos is a naturally occurring mineral
composed of millions of fibers
which bind together to create a light
yet virtually indestructible material.
The fiber structure of asbestos
makes it a really effective
electrical insulator,
and it's also heat resistant.
So it was widely used in
construction and fireproofing.
When I was growing up,
my parents actually had
asbestos in their ceiling.
And I also remembered that
both my elementary school
and middle school,
which were built in the late 1970s,
had gymnasiums with asbestos ceilings.
But as public health awareness
about the dangers of asbestos has grown,
the business of asbestos
removal has also grown.
Although asbestos isn't
commonly used anymore
in construction, some consumer products
can still contain trace
amounts of asbestos,
such as roofing materials.
And sometimes when you're watching TV,
you might see ads for asbestos abatement,
which is the safe containment
and removal of asbestos by professionals.
The link between exposure to asbestos
and mesothelioma has been heavily studied.
And in turn, asbestos use has
greatly declined over time.
Unfortunately though,
symptoms or signs of mesothelioma
may not appear until 20
or 50 years later or more
after exposure to asbestos
with initial symptoms,
including shortness of
breath and chest pain.
However, over time,
as we can see in the
lower part of this figure,
asbestosis exposure can result in damage
to and cancer of the pleura,
which are membranes that cover the lungs
and the inside of the
surrounding chest walls.
These pleura, and even the diaphragm,
which helps you breathe,
can become scarred, damaged,
and hardened from asbestos.
And of course,
mesothelioma can develop too.
What's even worse though
is that mesothelioma
is generally resistant
to radiation and chemotherapy treatments.
So long-term survival and
cures are exceedingly rare.
But mesothelioma can be
diagnosed and treated early
through regular cancer
screenings and blood tests
for those who may be most
vulnerable to this cancer.
That is to say folks who
have had exposure to asbestos
through their work like miners,
factory workers, insulation, installers,
and construction workers.
So take a breath,
take a sip of water.
These are simple things that
we take for granted each day,
yet pollution can threaten these
basic aspects of our lives.
When my asthma starts to act up,
I become acutely aware of
just how much pollution
affects my day-to-day health.
And thanks to regulatory legislation
like the Clean Air Act
and the Clean Water Act
in the United States,
we have longer and healthier lives here.
But this isn't the case everywhere,
nor is it the case for everyone.
So do your part and help to ensure
safe air and water for all.